we spare no effort and I do pay tribute  to Michel Barnier  we spared no effort to try and reconcile  madame mais red lines and her demands  with our firm duty to protect the  European Union and the integrity of the  internal market the withdrawal  agreements is the best and only possible  solution to that dilemma and I hope this  is something that will be well  understood this is a position the  Commission defends on your behalf the  vast majority of this Parliament  supports this and we will continue to do  that to protect the interests of  European citizens whether they live on  the continent or in the United Kingdom  thank you very much ma'am president  [Music]